hi i'm ewan mcgregor and these are some
of my
characters that i played
i'm not going to call them iconic you
can
[Music]
obi-wan kenobi
[Music]
the last two questions of every
interview i ever did
for years was would you do the sequel to
trainspotting and would you ever play
obi-wan kenobi again almost like
guaranteed that would be the last two
questions that people would sneak in at
the end when the public is saying that's
time's up
so i would always answer honestly and um
disney called me in eventually
to the the lucasfilm office in l.a and i
sat down with the lady called kiri and
she just said look we can see that
you're saying
that you would play obi-wan again we
just want to know if you mean it
do you want to
and i said yes i think there's there's
got to be a good story to tell between
episode 3 and episode 4. there's got to
be some great story there if we took
this character that people know and love
from alec guinness as this wise old sage
powerful spiritual man the work that i
did in one to three from a trainee jedi
padawan to somebody sitting on the on
the jedi council with yoda you know we
take him to a broken place that he's
faithless and broken
that would be interesting that'd be a
good interesting place to start the
fight is done
we lost
what happened to you
you were once a great jedi
the time of the jedi is over
[Music]
it was originally going to be a movie
stephen daldry was going to direct it at
one point we took workshops in new york
where we did you know brainstorming for
story lines and and then deborah chow
came on board and she sort of worked
with the writers in one direction then
it switched a very different story she's
really a brilliant director her vision
goes through all of the apps she
directed all the episodes which i think
was key you know she's really really
good
but playing him was
as easier in a way because i because i
think the sort of broken obi-wan kenobi
the solitary
lonely
character we find at the beginning of
the series is a bit closer to alec
guinness's obi-wan kedobi than my sort
of
swashbuckley you know general kenobi
that are running around on lizards and
stuff so i loved it very much and i and
i've always got to feel
alec guinness in my
head or sitting on my shoulder wherever
he is i've got to i've got to feel like
him to whatever degree when i'm playing
the role and and it was just felt that
bit closer to him there's more to life
than your farm owen
he needs to see that there's a whole
galaxy out there i'm asking you
to leave us alone ben i mean it
is he okay
you don't care if he's okay
you care if he's showing my
responsibility owen i'm his uncle we
talked about this when the time comes he
must be trained now after we've just
finished doing this television series
with the stagecraft set you know we're
surrounded by this huge dome that is an
lcd screen that they play the
backgrounds onto which is connected to
the camera reads the iris on the camera
it reads the movement of the camera so
as the camera moves the perspective of
the background will move
and
you shoot against it
and you don't have to put it on
afterwards it's there but for us it
means you're surrounded by what feels
like the real thing
raise your head
[Music]
i said raise your head
[Music]
if you're in the desert well there's a
desert set on the floor and everything
but everywhere you look around you
and above you is the desert and it feels
really real but if you're flying through
space and your spaceship
space is scutting past you the stars are
flying by you it feels much more
realistic
it's much more fun
big fish
big fish was my first time in the south
it was my first time in alabama anyway
and i loved it i asked them to rent me a
pickup truck and i drove myself to work
in my pickup truck every day
oh i loved it it was great it was
amazing working with tim burton i've
always hoped that that might happen
again and i still hope so i mean i love
his imagination and i think it's a
really important film for me it's a it's
a film that um a lot of men like and i
think because it's so
much about a father and a son some
people come up to speak to me thinking
about their dads and sometimes people
are talking about their sons but
it seems to hit a chord and that's
that's really nice when that happens
also i got to
make fantastical things happen i got to
work with elephants in a circus and it
was just an amazing experience to do
[Music]
i loved working with tim burton because
when he's between
action and cut it was just a sense of
play there was never really a a sense of
trying to get something right it just
felt like he's so free he's sort of like
a mad professor and
sort of tearing his hair out about
getting getting to shoot because you
know the jenny goes down and the light's
not working and this that the other
i can remember like his hair would get
higher and higher during the days like
because it's this impatience to shoot
one thing i'd never forget is making it
into the local newspaper for for
parallel parking so badly there's the
scene where i drive up with steve
buscemi in the charger and i have to
reverse into a spot
apparently i didn't do that very well
and it was written about mr mcgregor is
not a very good parker
holston
jeans are a fad
valenciaga didn't do fads and neither
will i fed i mean look at gavin klein he
sold me not coming to my office david to
mention that man's name i didn't know
who halston was when i was first
approached about the series and i think
that's possibly why i found him so
interesting because dan menehen the
director was showing me these
photographs of this man who was not a
clearly very glamorous pictures of him
arriving at studio 54 with people taking
his pictures and he described him as the
most famous man you've never heard of
i've always found that photographs are
very useful in terms of if you're
playing somebody who's really existed
yeah of course you can watch interviews
you can listen to their voice
there's something
that a photograph can capture
that tells you a lot about somebody and
with houston it was very much his hands
his fingers were always in the most
beautiful position
yes
i have this feeling like he sort of
curated his life you know he liked to
have camera crews around he started
filming everything so there's lots of
footage of him
i had my hair darkened to play him
because he had dark hair so when we went
back from lockdown i went back to la i
thought at first we were told you know
we're shutting down for two weeks
[Laughter]
but the first thing i did was after once
i realized
it wasn't gonna be quick that we went
back i i i wanted to try and lighten my
hair because i it's odd when you're you
but you don't look like you it's fine if
you're working on something but when i
was just off i so i went to the
supermarket and i got some
hair lightener i just bought it off the
shelf i thought this will do
my hair totally
peroxide like yellow white you know and
this like
[ __ ]
had a nightmare that they might call me
back to work you know like soon and i
would be turning back out with this like
orangey white hair oh my god
[Music]
our costume designer jerry anna was
amazing at teaching me how to make the
dresses that i am seen making in the
show i can't learn to be a
amazing dressmaker in you know a few
months so
what we did is we took each
each time you see me draping i just
learned
how to make those dresses like how you
would drape them and also just the act
of pinning i had to look like i knew
what i was doing i didn't want my hands
to sort of give me away you know he was
so
graceful and and i loved all the images
of him and he was always sort of behind
one of his models or whoever he was
draping and
look he was really
focused in the mirror and he had this he
had this thing where he he sort of
sucked in beauty you could see that his
eye just looked for beautiful things and
shapes and so he was always like peering
around somebody's hair
looking in the mirror and his fingers
were pinning the dress and he wasn't
looking like like i would be doing to
pin a dress so those scenes made me very
feel quite close to him
[Music]
birds of prey
i knew i was going to be playing halston
when i
made birds a prey and so um
might have been
i certainly was thinking about halston a
bit
is that a snot bubble
ill gross
oh i've changed my mind peel it off
there was something similar about the
grandiosity maybe i think roman wanted
everything to be in his control and i'm
pretty sure halston was like that about
his work it was just fun to play roman i
like that he could lose his temper like
in a blinking of an eye but like really
he goes from zero to a hundred with in a
split second there she is
she's a child this is sciatica she's
what we have harley quinn downstairs is
requesting the [ __ ] off get out [ __ ]
out
[ __ ] these are my things this diamond is
my things yes my things
[ __ ] [ __ ] i don't ask for much do i
there's lots of stuff that we improvised
in that film that didn't make it into
the film sadly we did that we improvised
this whole
hide-and-seek game in my apartment we
had this idea that when they were like
super high after getting back from the
club they'd play hide and seek he was
pretty good on the page but there was
more fun to be had with him and i i i
love the petulant
spoiled nature of him and that is
written in the writing with his
backstory that he came from very you
know he's kicked out of his family for
being the black sheep of the family and
he doesn't think he's a bad guy he
thinks he's just he just wants to take
over the world so yeah it was fun to
play all those moments thank you gq for
letting me talk through some of my
characters that i've played over the
years check out me talking about some of
my other characters on the british gq
channel